she's gained acclaim for films from the
wolf of wallstreet to once upon a time
in Hollywood but how much do you really
know about this multi-talented leading
lady from her humble origins to her
latest releases this is the true story
of Margot Robbie the fact that Margot
Robbie is Australian can come as a
surprise to even the most ardent fan of
course it's probably a testament to her
skill as an actor that this central part
of her life is so well camouflaged
people often think of Robbie with Tonya
Harding's flat intonation or Harley
Quinn's charmingly nasal singsong voice
what they don't realize is that she's as
positively Aussie as they come Robbie
grew up in the gold coast hinterland
part of the state of Queensland and
known worldwide for its natural beauty
everything from rainforest hikes
wine-tasting experiences and
bird-watching trips are enjoyed by the
countless number of tourists who flock
to this part of Australia every year but
Robbie herself spent much of her
childhood working one of four children
raised by a single mother
Robbie grew up travelling between her
mother's house and her grandparents farm
since her mother's family raised grain
and her father's family farmed sugarcane
and mangoes she grew up tending to a
wide variety of crops funnily enough
this actually ended up helping her
during filming on the post-apocalyptic
drama z for Zachariah as she joked in an
interview with Vanity Fair I already
knew how to drive a tractor in milk cows
to most of the world it would seem like
Robbie has had a meteoric rise in
Hollywood from the wolf of Wall Street
to Once Upon a Time in Hollywood she's
dominated the Cineplex for the past few
years with a treasure trove of
distinctive roles crass figure-skating
legend done Queen Elizabeth the first at
the height of a rivalry with Mary Queen
of Scots check Sharon Tate at the apex
of her career bingo and given her 2020
and Beyond slate is filled up with roles
like the eponymous doll in Barbie she
doesn't show any sign of slowing down
soon either but in her native Australia
it took all that buzz just to get people
to stop thinking of her as a soap opera
star cast in 2008 is Donna Friedman on
neighbours Robbie saw the character
through from guest part to recurring
role a confidence slightly goofy
character
Robbie turned Donna into a fan favorite
who audiences love to watch mature from
Team fangirl into fiery young woman she
did it so well in fact that she got
Logie award for popular actress and
acclaim for portraying Friedman's
bisexuality with compassion and courage
to most of the world robbie is a
bonafide movie star but too many
Australians she'll always be Donna the
routes to stardom are many and varied
sometimes all an actor really needs is
one chance to show their stuff sometimes
they're the right persons friend
sometimes they have a unique skill that
no one else can offer and sometimes
they're just enormous Lee heartwarmingly
Ernest Robbie has walked more than one
path on her way to stardom but that last
tak taken might be the most important of
all as she told Vogue I've always been a
huge huge Tarantino fan so huge in fact
that Robbie vowed the sentiment letter
expressing her appreciation once she
thought she'd gained enough prominence
to do so after producing and starring in
the award-winning I Tania
Robbie felt she had the backing to reach
out to the legendary director she later
recalled so I wrote him and said I adore
your films and I would love to work with
you in some capacity or any capacity
[Music]
Tarantino was charmed
Robbie was game and the exchange led to
her taking the role of Sharon Tate in
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood just goes
to show that sometimes all it takes is
an honest word one thing Margot Robbie's
life story has made very clear is her
drive and commitment to everything she
puts her name to it pushes her into
increasingly demanding acting roles
fascinating character choices and even
some surprising hobbies but her energy
isn't confined to her work in front of
the camera Robbie has also thrown
herself wholeheartedly into movie
production as well founded in 2017 her
lucky chap entertainment production
company hit the ground running in a
major way though birds of prey will be
their most high-profile early release
lucky chap has already sold its
half-hour series Dollface starring kat
dennings to hulu they've also premiered
the company's indie thriller Dream Land
and are gearing up for Barbies starring
Robbie as the titular doll being
involved on the production side of
Hollywood is a dream for many actors but
the passion dedication and sheer
tenacity it demands tends to deter most
of them not Robbie though lucky chap is
involved in an ever-expanding slate of
projects over the next few years
nearly all of them centering around
women and since Robbie has been wowing
audiences for years with her performing
acumen the chances are good shall
flourish behind the camera two suicide
squads lackluster reviews didn't matter
much when it came to Harley Quinn's own
fate even years after its release
Halloween is still pretty much just a
gathering of daddy's little monsters all
sporting Robbie's signature two-toned
pigtails on top of that Queen is set to
claim an animated series all her own and
Robbie will star in birds of prey
without the Joker in tow
Robbie isn't just starring in and
producing birds of prey however she
developed and pitched it herself to DC
after suicide squads debut in 2018 she
remarked I pitched the idea of an
r-rated girl gang film including Harley
because I was like Harley needs friends
Harley loves interacting with people so
don't ever make her do a standalone film
she's got to be with other people it
should be a girl gang as snippets of the
inventive costume design and hugely
exciting casting leaked into a Harley
hungry Internet the movie's anticipation
only has proved Robbie right the world
wants super heroines and she's the woman
to deliver it to them suicide squads
production and subsequent promotion was
as much of an event as the movie itself
Jared Leto shocked his cast mates by
offering them disturbing in character
gifts posters featured everything from
psychedelic cereal bowls to mushroom
clouds
perhaps most traumatic of all however
were the tattoos many of the cast got
matching squad tattoos spelled sk w ad
because well misspellings are cool to
commemorate their time together this
sparked a new interest for Robbie and
now the star has given tattoos to a
number of friends colleagues and loved
ones using a tattoo gun she bought on
eBay at first I had to really beg people
and then and then it kind of like it
became a thing and people asked me now
they're like oh okay oh no that'll be
funny though she doesn't claim much in
the way of skill and actually alleges
that she might be getting worse
her interest in the art of ink is real
if you're willing to get into Robbie's
chair like buddy Cara Delevingne was you
might just find yourself with something
as innocuous as smiley faces on the
bottom of your toes of course according
to Robbie they tend to rub off in a few
days due to the nature of the souls of
the
so hey why not do what Harley would do
and take a while chance actors garner a
lot of odd skills over the course of
their careers and Robbie is no exception
Suicide Squad had her doing a tremendous
amount of her own stunts according to
producer Richard suckle he explained I
went on set and I was watching the
monitor and the camera was moving but
she was doing something that I could
have sworn for sure she had to be in a
harness and I kid you not she was not in
a harness the sequence suckle is
referring to here is the infamous
elevator scene in which Harley runs up
the side of an elevator wall and
backflips onto a bad guy that's right
that was Robbie herself defying gravity
and spiked heels and a face full of
makeup but that's not even the most
impressive feat she pulled off as part
of DC's zany ode to the scum of the
superheroic world in order to film a
pivotal underwater scene
Robbie worked with the free diver and
learned to hold her breath for an
extended period of time I could do like
a resting breath hold of five minutes
which meant I could do like a hundred
five minutes underwater yeah which I
never thought was possible
Robbie might play a clown but she
certainly doesn't train like one
Robbie's character in the wolf of Wall
Street naomi LaPaglia is basically a
life-sized Barbie both in her beautiful
blonde looks and in the way her husband
Leonardo DiCaprio's Jordan Belfort
treats her like more of a possession
than a person and Robbie ended up
connecting to the character best through
of all things manicures after her acting
coach told her to imagine having just
had her nails done Robbie found herself
immediately able to channel the
characters brash Brooklyn attitude and
she ultimately requested acrylic nails
to further her performance she told the
New York Times
you can't tuck your hair back the way
you would you can't wipe away tears the
way you would because you've got nails
that are an inch long that's not the
only quirk that helped along her
performance though she also indulged in
a little liquid courage for some of her
more revealing scenes she later remarked
I did three shots of tequila and then
took my clothes off and did the scene
and I was fine acting 101 three shots of
tequila and you'll be fine in the age of
the omnipresent superhero more than one
actor has pulled double or even triple
duty Chris Evans Marvel's beloved
Captain America played the Human Torch
in 2005's Fantastic Four
l.jackson played the sort of psychotic
monster Nick Fury usually works to
thwart as the octopus in 2008's the
spirits Ben Affleck might not be Batman
anymore but he'll probably always be the
only guy who could say he played both
the Dark Knight and daredevil margot
robbie never actually got that far but
she came close when she passed on
playing Sue Storm in 2015's Fantastic
Four she told the New York Daily News I
didn't really resonate with the script
but I had a great meeting with the
director and I really enjoyed that I
guess it's part of the game sometimes
you win some sometimes you lose some and
you can't help but wonder if she might
feel as though she dodged a bullet
Fantastic Four in which kate mara played
Sue Storm ended up a critical disaster
in a box office bomb with no further
installments in sight margot robbie is
no stranger to the physical demands of
the actor's life she learned to ice
skate like an olympian for the title
role in hi Tanya in addition to taking
part in rigorous weight training Harley
Quinn had her strapping on ankle weights
in exploring Pilates but there's one
line she won't cross and she found it
while preparing for a role in The Legend
of Tarzan producers wanted her Jane
Porter
Tarzan's legendary love interest to look
even more slender than Robbie normally
does Robbie pushed back arguing it's the
19th century in the film if she's got a
bit of weight on her it's probably a
good thing I'm not going to look thin
just for the sake of it Robbie got her
way and her Jane Porter is a ferocious
delight to behold check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one